do you think so many people pretend like
they care about you because that's one
thing where you don't get hung up on its
I'm envious sometimes I'm like [ __ ] the
amount of free time that daliyah must
have yeah sometimes and not that easy
not so busy but just said like the free
time you must have because you don't
placate yeah that's a cooter bro you
know what I mean mm-hmm
yeah I know you could do it no you you
get it he [ __ ] knows he has it on his
back it's about it's about a [ __ ]
it's about you know barracudas when they
see the [ __ ] shiny [ __ ] they go
towards it you know if you if you're
fishing you catch a barracuda you got a
bracelet on that's your [ __ ] ass you
know cuz we're crews all what a thing
and they grab it right dude
that's if you can't be like that as a
person you can't be like what Coachella
everybody's going let's go that's a CUDA
bro I'm not I'm not about that right
no like you I'm and maybe I miss out on
a lot of [ __ ] you know camping kuda we
built all these walls yeah we figured it
out why the [ __ ] you want to get away
from it right why do you want to go back
out you know I'm saying so what have
there been coot things that recruiters
in your life and you're like now you
came back to me like off I mean look
like you know we're all I always say on
my podcast we're all a little bit kuda
you know what I mean because you have to
have that sort of like a thing where
you're like oh [ __ ] like I want to like
like I have an addictive personality for
sure like that that's like the hundred
percent and I don't do drugs and I never
have and I realize that that's that's
that was like a blessing in disguise
right because I don't ever do anything I
have all these stupid rules but like you
look like a dude that would help drugs
too so a definite fit yeah in my car
like kilos yeah and I don't but I don't
have I I don't I have all these stupid
rules like one of my things like I don't
do anything until I regret that I
haven't done it like I lost my virginity
after I felt like oh [ __ ] I should have
had sex with that girl OS and I was 19 I
waited awhile you know yeah but I never
had that moment where I was like oh
everybody did [ __ ] smoke weed I
wasn't involved
I should have been right I never had
that moment so I never I never did it so
you kind of it's interesting then you
say you don't get tempted in the butt
you get you get tenth do not get tempted
in the beginning or do you have this
just something built in you where you
wait till have some foresight does that
make any sense
um yeah
really like that I just don't I just if
if everybody's doing a thing it makes
you question yeah you question first I'm
just like what is that what's going on
it just puts me off it it's not even
that I'm questioning it I'm just like
right like like the number one thing
about that is frats like I have never
join a frat join right join something
are you out of your mind
join something my grandfather used to
tell my dad
you never volunteer for anything be
that's hilarious
that's hilarious and as a kid I was like
what but now I get it do it yeah it's
like that little Wayne song on me dude
yeah get out of here frat yeah have you
met little Wayne no no evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one